et comment tout revient à la mode d'une manière ou d'une autre.
Quelques bières de plus, j'ai dit, « Il doit y avoir quelque chose
qui n'est pas revenue. » (Rires)
Une autre bière et on est passé à ce qu'est arrivé à la moustache.
Pourquoi n'est-elle pas revenue ? (Rires)
Puis on a bu encore plus de bières et la journée s'est terminée
avec le défi lancé de faire revenir la moustache. (Rires)
En Australie, « mo » c'est l'argot pour moustache,
nous avons donc rebaptisé le mois de novembre, « Movember »
et nous avons créé des règles assez basiques, qui existent encore aujourd'hui,
C'est-à-dire : on commence le mois complètement rasé,
on fait pousser une moustache -- pas une barbe, pas une barbichette, une moustache --
pendant les 30 jours de novembre, et ensuite nous avons convenu
de nous revoir à la fin du mois,
de participer à une fête à thème moustache et décerner un prix
à la meilleure, et bien sûr à la pire moustache. (Rires)
Croyez-moi, faire pousser une moustache
en 2003, et nous étions 30,
et c'était avant le mouvement branché de la moustache
-- (Rires) --
ça a soulevé beaucoup de controverse. (Rires)
Mon patron ne me laissait pas visiter mes clients.
Ma petite amie de l'époque, qui n'est plus ma petite amie -- (Rires) -- détestait ma moustache.
Les parents éloignaient les enfants de nous. (Rires)
Mais nous nous sommes revus à la fin du mois
et nous avons fêté notre trajet, et ça a vraiment été un voyage.
Nous nous sommes bien amusés, et en 2004, j'ai dit à mes copains,
« C'était tellement amusant. Il faut le légitimer
pour pouvoir le faire chaque année. » (Rires)
Nous y avons réfléchi et nous nous sommes inspirés
des femmes qui nous entouraient et de ce qu'elles faisaient pour le cancer du sein.
Nous avons pensé, vous savez, il n'y a rien pour la santé masculine,
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi ne pas associer le fait de faire pousser une moustache
à la santé masculine ?
J'ai commencé à rechercher sur le sujet et j'ai découvert
que le cancer de la prostate est l'équivalent chez l'homme du cancer du sein
en termes de nombre d'hommes qui en meurent et qui en sont diagnostiqués.
Mais il n'y avait rien pour cette cause,
nous avons donc marié la moustache avec le cancer de la prostate,
et nous avons ensuite créé le slogan, qui est,
« Changer le visage de la santé masculine. »
Et ça représente de manière éloquente le défi,
de changer votre apparence pendant 30 jours,
et le résultat que nous essayons d'atteindre;
pousser les hommes à s'engager à leur santé, les faire
mieux comprendre les risques auxquelles ils font face.
Donc avec ce modèle,
j'ai ensuite appelé le PDG de la Fondation du Cancer de la Prostate
Je lui ai dit, « J'ai une idée géniale
qui va transformer votre organisation. » (Rires)
Je ne voulais pas partager l'idée par téléphone,
je l'ai donc convaincu de me voir pour un café à Melbourne
en 2004.
Nous nous sommes assis, et j'ai partagé avec lui ma vision
de convaincre les hommes à se faire pousser la moustache dans toute l'Australie,
en augmentant la prise de conscience pour la cause,
et les fonds pour son organisation. j'avais besoin d'un partenaire
pour le faire légitimement.
J'ai dit, « Nous allons nous revoir à la fin,
nous ferons une moustache-party, nous aurons des DJ,
nous célèbrerons la vie et nous changerons le visage de la santé masculine. »
Il m'a regardé en rigolant, et il a dit,
« Adam, c'est vraiment une idée originale,
mais nous sommes une organisation ultraconservatrice.
Nous n'avons rien à voir avec vous. » (Rires)
J'ai payé le café ce jour-là -- (Rires) --
et son commentaire final en me quittant a été,
« Ecoutez, si vous arrivez à lever des fonds,
nous les prendrons avec plaisir. » (Rires)
Ma leçon cette année-là a été la persévérance.
Nous avons insisté, et nous avons trouvé 450 gars
qui se sont fait pousser la moustache et ensemble nous avons ramassé 54 000 dollars,
et nous avons donné jusqu'au dernier centime à la Fondation pour le Cancer de la Prostate australienne,
ce qui a représenté à l'époque le don unique le plus important
qu'ils ont jamais reçu.
A partir de ce jour-là, ma vie n'est qu'une moustache.
Chaque jour -- ce matin, je me lève et c'est parti, ma vie
est consacrée à la moustache. (Rires)
En fait, je suis un agriculteur de la moustache. (Rires)
Ma saison c'est le mois de novembre. (Applaudissements)
(Applaudissements)
En 2005, la campagne a pris de l'élan,
elle a eu plus de succès en Australie et en Nouvelle Zélande,
ensuite en 2006 nous sommes arrivés à un point crucial.
Ça nous demandait tellement de temps le soir
et pendant les weekends que nous avons pensé :
soit nous arrêtons, soit nous trouvons un moyen de financer Movember
pour que je puisse quitter mon boulot et investir plus de temps
dans l'organisation et l'amener à un niveau supérieur.
C'est très intéressant qu'avec des efforts, vous arrivez à trouver un moyen
de financer une organisation qui collecte des fonds,
construite sur la culture de la moustache. (Rires)
Je vous assure qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup de gens intéressés
à y investir, pas même pour la Fondation du Cancer de la Prostate,
pour laquelle nous avons levé 1,2 millions de dollars à ce stade.
Nous avons donc insisté de nouveau, et le producteur de bières Foster est venu à la fête
et nous a proposé notre toute première sponsorisation,
ce qui était suffisant pour moi pour quitter mon boulot et faire du conseil.
En arrivant à Movember 2006,
nous avons dépensé tout l'argent de Foster,
nous avons dépensé tout l'argent que j'avais
et essentiellement il ne nous restait plus rien, et nous avions convaincu tous nos fournisseurs --
les agences de créativité, les agences de développement web,
les sociétés d'hébergement web, et ainsi de suite -- à retarder les paiements jusqu'au mois de décembre.
A ce stade nous avions accumulé 600 000 dollars
de dettes. Donc en l'absence de Movember 2006,
nous le fondateurs, nous aurions fait faillite tous les quatre
sans un toit, dans la rue
avec une moustache. (Rires)
Mais nous avons pensé, vous savez quoi, si c'est le pire
qui peut nous arriver, et alors?
Nous allons quand même nous amuser et ça nous a appris
l'importance de prendre des risques et des risques très intelligents.
Ensuite au début de 2007, il s'est passé quelque chose de très intéressant.
Des Mo Bros du Canada, des Etats Unis,
et du Royaume Uni nous ont écrit et nous ont appelés pour dire,
hé, il n'y a rien pour le cancer de la prostate.
Amenez cette campagne dans ces pays.
Nous avons donc pensé ? Pourquoi pas.
J'ai donc appelé le PDG de Cancer de la Prostate au Canada,
et je lui ai dit, « J'ai ce concept extraordinaire. »
(Rires)
« Ça va transformer votre organisation. Je ne vais pas
tout vous raconter maintenant, mais voulez-vous me rencontrer
si je vous rejoins à Toronto ? » J'ai donc pris l'avion,
je l'ai rencontré sur Front Street East, nous nous sommes assis dans la salle de conseil,
et j'ai dit, « Très bien, voici ma vision de faire pousser la moustache aux hommes
dans tout le Canada, afin d'augmenter la prise de conscience et de financer votre organisation. »
Il m'a regardé, il a rigolé et il a dit,
« Adam, ça me parait une idée originale, mais nous sommes
une organisation ultraconservatrice. » (Rires)
J'ai déjà entendu ça. Je sais comment ça marche.
Mais il a dit, « Nous allons collaborer avec vous,
mais nous n'allons pas y investir. Vous devez trouver un moyen
d'amener la campagne ici et la faire marcher. »
Ce que nous avons fait c'est prendre de l'argent
que nous avons levé en Australie et amener la campagne
dans ce pays, les Etats Unis, le Royaume Uni et nous l'avons fait
parce que nous savions que si ça marchait
nous aurions pu lever globalement beaucoup plus d'argent
qu'en Australie uniquement. Et cet argent
alimente la recherche et cette recherche nous mènera à un traitement.
Et nous n'allons pas trouver un traitement australien
ou un traitement canadien, nous allons trouver le traitement.
Donc en 2007, nous avons amené la campagne ici,
j'ai organisé la campagne.
ça n'a pas été un succès comme nous l'imaginions.
A l'époque nous étions un peu trop enthousiastes de notre succès
en Australie et en Nouvelle Zélande.
Cette année nous a vraiment appris l'importance de la patience
et de comprendre vraiment le marché local
avant de fixer des objectifs trop élevés.
Mais ce que j'ai le plaisir de dire c'est qu'en 2010,
Movember est devenu un vrai mouvement global.
Le Canada s'est fait souffler la victoire
pour la meilleure campagne de collecte de fonds au monde.
L'année dernière nous avions 450 000 Mo Bros dans le monde entier
et ensemble nous avons levé 77 millions de dollars.
(Applaudissements)
Ce qui fait de Movember le plus gros financeur
pour la recherche et le soutien du cancer de la prostate au monde.
C'est un résultat merveilleux si vous pensez
que nous faisons pousser la moustache. (Rires)
Et de notre point de vue, nous avons redéfini les organisations caritatives.
Notre ruban c'est un ruban poilu. (Rires)
Nos ambassadeurs sont les Mo Bros et les Mo Sistas,
et je crois que ça a été fondamental pour notre succès.
Nous remettons la marque et notre campagne à ces gens-là.
Nous les laissons s'y engager et l'interpréter à leur propre façon.
Je vis maintenant à Los Angeles, parce que
la Fondation pour le Cancer de la Prostate des Etats Unit est basée là-bas,
et je suis toujours interrogé par les médias là-bas,
à cause du culte de la célébrité,
« Qui sont vos ambassadeurs célèbres ? »
Et je leur dit, « L'année dernière nous avons eu la chance
d'avoir 450 000 ambassadeurs célèbres. »
Et ils répondent: « Que voulez-vous dire ? »
Chaque personne, chaque Mo Bro
et Mo Sista qui participe à Movember
est notre ambassadeur célèbre, et c'est tellement important
et essentiel pour notre succès.
Ce que je veux partager avec vous c'est
un des moments les plus touchant de Movember,
qui s'est passé ici à Toronto l'année dernière,
à la fin de la campagne.
J'étais sorti avec mon équipe. C'était vers la fin de Movember.
Nous avions fait une campagne superbe, et pour être honnête,
nous avions bu pas mal de bières cette nuit, mais j'ai dit,
« Vous savez quoi, je crois que nous pouvons faire un autre bar. » (Rires)
Nous sommes tous montés dans un taxi, et voici notre chauffeur,
j'étais assis sur la banquette arrière, il s'est tourné
et il a dit, « Vous allez où ? »
J'ai dit, « Attend, c'est une moustache superbe. »
(Rires)
Il a répondu, « Je la fait pour Movember ». Et j'ai dit,
« Moi aussi. » Et j'ai dit, « Racontez-moi votre histoire Movember. »
Et il me révele, « Ecoutez, je sais que c'est pour la santé masculine,
je sais que c'est pour le cancer de la prostate, mais la mienne est pour le cancer du sein. »
J'ai dit, « Voilà qui est intéressant. »
Et il me dit, « L'année dernière ma mère est décédée du cancer du sein au Sri Lanka,
parce que nous ne pouvions pas lui payer les bons traitements »,
et il a continué, « Cette moustache est un hommage à ma mère. »
Nous étions submergés par l'émotion à l'arrière du taxi,
et je ne lui ai pas dit qui j'étais, car je croyais que ce n'était pas approprié,
je lui ai serré la main et j'ai dit, « Merci beaucoup.
Votre maman serait fière de vous. »
A partir de ce moment, je me suis rendu compte que Movember
c'est tellement plus qu'une simple moustache pour s'amuser.
Ce sont des gens qui viennent sur cette plateforme,
qui l'épousent à leur façon,
pour que ça ait un sens dans leurs vies.
Nous à Movember, nous nous concentrons
sur ces domaines pour avoir un vrai impact :
connaissance et éducation,
les programmes de soutien des survivants et la recherche.
Nous nous concentrons naturellement sur les fonds à lever,
parce que c'est un résultat concret, mais pour moi,
la connaissance et l'éducation sont plus importantes que les fonds que nous levons,
car je sais que ça change et ça sauve des vies aujourd’hui,
et c'est probablement mieux représenté
par un homme que j'ai rencontré au South by Southwest
à Austin, Texas, en début d'année.
Il est venu me voir et m'a dit, « Merci pour avoir commencé Movember. »
Et j'ai dit, « Merci de faire Movember. »
Je l'ai regardé et je lui ai dit, « Je suis plutôt sûr que vous ne pouvez pas vous faire pousser une moustache. » (Rires)
Et je lui ai demandé, « Quelle est votre histoire Movember ? »
Il m'a répondu, « J'ai fait pousser la pire moustache qui soit. » (Rires)
« Mais je suis rentré chez moi pour le diner de Thanksgiving et assez rapidement
la conversation autour de la table a viré
sur ce qui était en train de se passer. » (Rires)
« Nous avons parlé -- Je leur ai parlé de Movember,
et ensuite, mon père s'est approché, et à 26 ans
pour la première fois, j'ai eu une conversation avec mon père
sur la santé masculine. J'ai eu une conversation
avec mon père sur le cancer de la prostate et j'ai appris
que mon grand-père avait eu le cancer de la prostate
et j'ai pu partager avec mon père qu'il avait
deux fois plus de possibilités d'attraper la maladie, il ne le savais pas,
et il n'avait pas passé de test de dépistage. »
Alors, cet homme passera maintenant un test de dépistage.
Ces conversations qui incitent les hommes à s'y engager,
à n'importe quel âge sont tellement importantes,
et à mon avis encore plus importantes
que les fonds que nous levons.
Maintenant pour les fonds que nous levons, la recherche
et la manière dont nous sommes en train de redéfinir la recherche.
Nous finançons des fondations pour le cancer de la prostate dans 13 pays.
Nous finançons des centaines voire des milliers d'institutions
et chercheurs dans le monde, et en regardant
plus récemment, nous nous sommes aperçus
de l'absence de collaboration même entre les institutions
encore plus au niveau national et international, et ça ne se limite pas
au cancer de la prostate. C'est la recherche sur le cancer dans le monde entier.
Nous nous sommes dits, très bien, nous avons redéfini les organisations caritatives.
Il nous faut maintenant redéfinir la manière de travailler de ces gens-là. Mais comment ?
Et alors, ce que nous avons fait c'est de créer un plan d'action global,
nous prenons 10% de ce que nous collectons dans chaque pays
et nous le mettons dans un fond global, et nous avons
les meilleurs chercheurs sur le cancer de la prostate dans le monde
qui s'occupent du fond,
ils se rassemblent chaque année pour identifier
les premières priorités,
l'année dernière, c'était la réalisation d'un meilleur test de dépistage.
Ils ont identifié ceci comme priorité et ensuite
ils ont recruté 300 chercheurs
du monde entier qui étudiaient le sujet,
fondamentalement le même sujet.
Maintenant nous les finançons avec à peu près
cinq ou six millions de dollars pour collaborer
et se rassembler, et c'est assez exceptionnel
dans le monde du cancer, et nous savons qu'à travers une telle collaboration,
cela va accélérer les résultats.
Et voilà comment nous redéfinissons le monde de la recherche.
Ce que je sais sur mon parcours de Movember c'est que,
avec une idée vraiment créative,
avec la passion, la persévérance et beaucoup de patience,
quatre copains, quatre moustaches,
peuvent inspirer une salle pleine de gens,
et cette salle pleine de gens peut inspirer une ville,
et cette ville c'est Melbourne, chez moi.
Et cette ville peut continuer à inspirer un état, et cet état
à son tour inspire une nation et au-delà de ça,
on peut créer un mouvement global
qui change le visage de la santé masculine.
Je m'appelle Adam Garone, et vous venez d’écouter mon histoire.
Merci. (Applaudissements)